Did you know you could do this?
With a little bit of height, and by mashing R1,
you can instantly take out these chariots -
and everything around them, for that matter.
The hitbox for this is so janky though..and
while sometimes that's a good thing - this note
says it best: your "Opportunities for a
plunging attack, will be rare indeed"
This game is absolutely brimming with hidden
content..and this secrets video is going to be
the first of many on Elden Ring, so subscribe
for that. In this video, we'll be going through
all the noteworthy secrets that From Software
were kind enough to write down for us - most
of which you can buy from the merchants
found throughout the game..and at the end,
we'll also talk about the dark secret..of
the merchants, themselves.
Now, for this first one, I want to help
you try and defeat an enemy that I know
a lot of you have been having trouble
with (show crucible knight duo)
The land squirts. I mean they're so hard
and need to be nerfed, honestly..it's
bullshit..but until then - try poison.
It's counter-intuitive, but poisoning these things
overloads them with toxin, and they can't expel
it fast enough..so they tragically explode in
their own poison cloud. This, in turn..poisons the
land squirts around them..who explode..and..so on,
and so on. It's kind of sad watching them fall
victim to their own poison in this way...but
also strangely satisfying.
The same strategy can be used against
the giant land squirts found in northeastern
Liurnia..and the scarlet rot variant found in
Caelid, which can also be overloaded with scarlet
rot. Pick your poison. Or don't, and knock them
over with a couple of R2's instead.
Another counter-intuitive strategy can be
used against the Royal Revenants, who
are actually extremely difficult, and
never really give you a chance to heal.
That said..if you do get a chance to
heal..well..they might just take damage, instead.
Any AOE heal can be used to kill them in this
way - powerful heals, especially so.
The same applies to their followers,
who are all cursed. Thus, your heals
will harm, rather than mend. Curiously,
you can even poison them with healing over time
spells, which is great, if you want to make them
suffer. And I know a lot of you do.
Another contender for most hated enemy
are the Stormveil Warhawks..particularly
the ones that peg fire barrels at you.
Use gravity magic however, and you can devastate
them. The same goes for any flying foe,
who will be brought low by spells like Gravity
Well, or ashes of war like Gravitas.
Another enemy you can bring low are the
Stonedigger Trolls, whose heads bear old wounds.
With one well aimed ranged attack...as
they roar - they'll be left reeling,
giving you ample time to charge some R2's
and bring them to their knees.
And then there are the notes that aren't really
worth the paper they're printed on. Slay the
demi-human mob's leader first, and the rest will
lose hope and panic. I mean..you should probably
always be killing the little guys first, if
you can. So I'm not sure how helpful this one
will be to you guys, but there it is.
It is cool to see their tribal dependence
on a leader, from a lore point of
view, though. Perhaps the demi-humans
fled Fort Haight when their
Speaking of things you can't see, have
you come across an invisible Black Knife Assassin,
before? They're tough..I only beat my first with
the help of spirit summons that helped me predict
it. Luckily though, there's a better way.
The merchant in the Hermit Merchant's
Shack sells a Sentry's Torch, bestowed
with a special incantation that allows the
bearer to see assassins cloaked in veils.
It was this invisibility that allowed the
Black Knives to steal the rune of death and
slay Godwyn the Golden. Thus, sentry torches
were given to the erdtree sentries such that a
night of black knives would never come again
Another type of light is commonly seen in hero
graveyards. It stems from Rosus's staff, and can
be used to make shadow enemies vulnerable.
While you're going through these dungeons,
remember - sometimes enemies need to be defeated,
in order for you to progress.
Speaking of Rosus, this is a character
you see all throughout the lands between. He
is the "Usher of Death", and when his statues
are activated, they shine a light that points
towards a dungeon. Sometimes, what he's pointing
to is obvious..and sometimes, the light is
pointing you towards dungeons that are very
hidden indeed. Specifically though, this light
always points towards catacomb-type dungeons.
After all - the dead easily lose
their way, and have always been in
sore need of a guiding hand.
For number 10 - "there is a hidden cave
in the town of Sellia. Look beyond
the graveyard at the precipice".
So..yeah..they're using the term "town" pretty
loosely here. You have go go quite far north
find the illusory wall behind the graveyard.
This is the Sellia Hideaway. A glintstone cavern
that you'll need to find at one point if
you're on Sorceress Sellen's questline. Her
questline leads you through a locked door found
within - but if you're not on that questline,
you can also pick up a Crystal Torrent spell ...
A crystal Spear ... and the Crystallian Ashes,
which are an excellent summon against anything
that doesn't use blunt damage.
The whole merchant class are intriguing - and
we'll get to their secrets in a moment. The
best of them though is Kale, of course,
who helps you kick of Blaiid's questline.
After hearing a howling in the woods,
speak to him, and he'll say this.
Perform the emote here..and I'll let
you see where this questline leads.
Here's where things start to get
curious. Note that the merchant is
telling you to stay away from this place.
A lot of folks would have missed this location,
since it requires you double back from the
Grand Lift of Dectus. Get past the tower
inflicting you with madness, as you once hid from
the Brain of Mensis in Bloodborne, that afflicted
you with Frenzy. Atop the tower is the Howl of
Shabriri spell. At the precipice of the cliff,
is the Frenzied Flame Village. Here, you can
get the Shabriri's Woe talisman..the Frenzied
Cookbook..and have an encounter with Vyke, who
drops a frenzy spear and a grape for Hyetta,
whose questline also goes down the path I'm about
to describe. Most curious in this village though,
is that there's another note. A clue,
leading you further down the path.
Like the others, this is also
written by a merchant..and
this one tells us who their lord is.
"Beneath Leyndell, at the very bottom
lies our lord, lord of the frenzied. The
Three Fingers who holds us in thrall"
This note prompted me to explore further
beyond the sewers..to find the boss fight
with Mohg. Then, knowing this couldn't possibly
be the end, it prompted me yet further..to
activate the passageway behind him, and find
the thousand odd corpses of frenzied folk that
look..just like the merchants. They even have
those same hand scratcher violin tools.
I'll let you venture down here and discover
this place for yourself. At the bottom..is
a very curious door. One that most characters
won't be able to open, straight away.
So here's the 14th secret, which I'll
provide: and I'm going to make it a
riddle for you - because damn, not everything
should be solved by looking up a wiki, you
know? In these early days of a games's release,
it's nice to find out stuff yourself. Probably
hypocritcal coming from a YouTuber, but I do want
to try to preserve your experience in some ways,
where I can. So here's my riddle: only
the wretched can get past this door.
Further up though, is another note. And it has
the final clue, in case you regret the ending
this door will take you to. To get this note,
trick a frenzied enemy into destroying the one of
these makeshift huts. The note within reads.
"The Empyrean Miquella crafted a needle to resist
the influence of the outer gods. Those
who have inherited the flame of frenzy,
yet wish not to become its lord would
do well to seek Miquella's Needle."
In order to get Miquella's needle, you'll need to
follow Millicent's questline all the way to the
end. It starts with Gowry, here in Caelid - and
ends all the way at the Haligtree, with Melenia.
Once you have this needle, you can embed it in
your flesh before this boss at Faram Azula - and
the flame of frenzy will no longer have
power over you, and your ending.
I..want to talk more about this, but it would
end up being a 30 minute lore video. I love that
this secrets video ended here though - it's just a
small taste of what to come.. as Elden Ring's lore
is...maddeningly addictive. All I want to do is
talk about it, but I do have to make sure I do all
the proper research first, so please, subscribe,
in anticipation of what's to come. And before I
go, please consider listening to Audible, who
graciously sponsored this video.
Now it's no secret that if you love
the worldbuilding of Elden Ring,
then you'll probably love the world of the Witcher
as well. My favourite way to dive into this world
isn't actually through the games, however..it's
through the audiobook. This is "The Last Wish",
a collection of short stories that went on to
inspire the Witcher games. Have a listen.
1:15
The Stranger was not old,
but his hair was almost entirely white ...
There's no room to be had. We don't need people
like you in Vichim.
2:39
You can listen to this full audiobook, or any
other, completely free during your trial period.
So, head over to audible.com/vaatividya,
or text vaatividya to 500 500,
and consider signing up.
This audiobook is read by
Peter Kenny, who as you heard - does an
excellent job with character accents and
inflections. Another reason I think
people will love this listen - is that
it's a collection of short stories, which
is perfect for the audiobook format since
you can finish an entire story while you listen on
the bus, or while you're doing some housework.
So again, head over to audible.com/vaatividya,
or text vaatividya to 500 500 to start
your free trial. Thanks to audible for
sponsoring this video - and thank you, for
watching.